i have big hands so i like small
keyboard you have small hands so you
like big keyboard no small keyboard
small boy i'm back
you should just learn how to take on an
xbox controller i picked that up knows
we live together oh yeah i know i know
yeah it was weird i was on the top bunk
and you know in the middle of the night
sometimes my
whole mattress would just rise up
bob control your morning wood
jesus christ that's true yeah it's true
true story why is your name censored
when's my name censored what the [ __ ]
is censored
this is ridiculous
do we have to call you
now yeah please do all right we're only
going to do one of these because we can
only handle one of these what if we just
have the best time of our lives and we
just want to keep going yeah what if
they changed it so much that it's really
awesome if it's good now yeah what if
what if there is a power bar in this
game right
sounds where they want all the
background noises turned off ready to
roll roll
oh hell yeah
yeah sure yeah all right time for our
intros
what golf
all right that's it you guys still do
intros that's cringey that's cool i do
an intro you're only saying that because
you never had one
i have an intro what is your what is
your intro what is that hey
i'm sorry what is what are everyone
else's intros oh do you even have to ask
yeah man whatever
does not mess around at all
i don't know how you spin god damn it
why am i an acorn oh my god this hammer
almost destroyed me oh my god
do you see how close to death i am
oh my god why am i a
oh you hit me yeah now you're extreme
now you have a helmet ball what are you
why are you oh you're an egg
those are always there or oh
why was i at five i was a ball the whole
time why was i a square who turned on
random shapes
oh the host must have done that we
didn't agree to that we didn't agree you
weren't here you went to take a [ __ ] why
are you doing it
horrible
i'm a croissant is that good what is a
honey trap
what am i smart it makes everyone else
get stuck as they're trying to roll
through it all right that's fair oh okay
should we aim for those boxes are they
like yeah the box these are the little
bonus things you can do like the honey
trap and whatnot yeah
oh [ __ ]
hey 777 good job boys hey wow look at
that
oh
who is what terrorist the flag i don't
know man oh oh oh oh oh
why did you do that to me
oh
nice are you kidding me
bob i don't think you're supposed to go
up there
i didn't
mean to oh okay
oh no i love your little boat my dude
yeah you like my hello guys he's really
helping me
why does your hat flip back and forth
it's exciting
you can do it
we're all winning right yeah we're all
winning
well
i'm winning three of us are pretty close
i'm winning
where is this oh
oh wait i see the big i see the big uh
finger
so if i make that
finger
no no no no no no no don't touch me
hey finger how you doing oh come on oh
yeah baby yeah baby
yeah
whoa what
what
please i can't actually go in
oh
guys i'm stuck yeah no but i'm stuck on
the geometry i'm not stuck in the honey
i'm my ball is literally jammed i got
him underneath guys
you okay mark guys i my ball is
literally hang on
oh yeah there we go
roll in baby oh come on sounds like
nothing
about nothing no
ah
who put honey right in front of me what
[ __ ] the tree is this yeah who
[ __ ] did that i don't know oh i can't
you're gonna thought you were gonna puck
back
[Laughter]
damn
this is awful we start over i wait
you chose random shapes
you chose that
last shot
wow that's a lot of shots i didn't even
know there was a limit
back into second place
[Music]
why does it change so quickly who's
changing it sometimes it stays a long
time sometimes it doesn't someone's
changing it who's changing maybe you're
changing hey is that dream
[Laughter]
oh no i just oh i just honeyed myself
wait what are you looking at oh i see
that's a good one thanks i'll be here
all game
no
go in oh thank god
the acorn is not nice i was awesome
there we go
who's on top now i want to know who's
changing the shapes i want to know
wade is he you no i haven't changed
shapes yet how do you even do that
whenever you have it right now my power
ups double oh it's like mario kart you
want to drive through the question
blockies you didn't realize that
you're doing great buddy whoa
oh and i screwed it so hard
i'm gonna wait
until i change shape
any minute now
you have two minutes i will be a
beautiful butterfly
in a mere mome
just you wait i'm waiting i'm gonna
hatch
uh-huh
hatch butterfly hold on
at least i know i've got a two minute
break to use the restroom
hold
on why am i not changing
guys
why am i not changing i feel it takes a
while to turn into a butterfly
yeah maybe uh here
oh okay okay
i'll take it i'll take it don't take it
hey
oh well it's not fun if we all have that
where is oh why why is
hey what's up okay oh my god you guys
i'm so freaking good at this game
[ __ ] am i
oh my god i got a birdie guys
wait
i can't move no mark no uh i can't move
i can't power buyer what help oh god i'm
different now
almost
you just cost me like three strokes you
should call me like three strokes mark
how did you hang on get where you are
hold on you fell off god damn don't make
the one jump you end up in the water
yeah you fell off you're in a real bad
shape there mark hold on hold on
i'll put some spin pizzazz
here we go jump over the wall
oh wait
[Music]
there was no way that was
i did a great job
how dare you say we suck for being
better than you god damn it i'm a
[ __ ] acorn again eat my honey let's
score last [ __ ] oh my god hold on one oh
that was only supposed to be me
oh wow are you
guys one of us didn't get a hole in one
oh no buddy
yeah cause a lot of us is not a flat
object hey look i'm still on the
leaderboard it's okay
we're all on the leader we didn't fall
off the leaderboard so we're good i go
first guys we're top four guys i've
somehow made
oh no oh
god maybe knocked me back the other way
maybe knock me
oh
no i can't make this jump man it feels
good you got a randomizer they want to
pop off
oh come on
oh well you could have done that before
i shot but
okay
so you guys do have randomizers that can
change objects it is us
yeah it is
hey you're a ball no you're not
no
god damn it you get over this easy i
don't know man
oh my giant cone where's my money i put
to screw you guys
oh
it went
[Laughter]
are you out of
stroke no
power bar
oh did you right click you might be
spinning up
for some reason i could jump and that's
it all right maybe here we go
you got this you got this one
nope one shot
whoa whoa
baby
my eyes i don't finish in small strokes
excellent work team
right
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm not gonna go that way you make your
ass buddy thanks
oh my god oh man i think you might be
onto something mark
yeah i think i might be on to something
oh
oh
oh oh oh
come on
oh no not that way
okay that was bad oh yeah don't go don't
go the balloon route
oh god i just went backwards god damn it
all right here we go easy peasy
yes
[Music]
i didn't go straight
with the side path turns out it's easier
one time i went straight zero times all
right i'll get this
oh no not like this
what what are you going after no way why
why am i my mother
what what okay oh my god i'm so good at
this game
suck it mark what
what i will not suck it mark okay
i'm not going to
you can't stop you
why is randomizer not working guys why
am i not changing any shape
i think you change our shape everyone
well then change my shape guys
we have been do it now
come on man just you're so close just
get in there
[Music]
i've got a strategy guys how is a
cylinder supposed to do this
i don't even know what i am here i go oh
god that was a mistake are you okay
eat random
[Music]
oh why did you watch me
oh why honey here why honey what why did
i have to be a cube for this get random
please help what i had hon i didn't have
honey trap i had random why is it
suddenly honey
what no no no no why
man that hole was bad that hole was
tough guys oh god acorn can't do yeah
randomly
randomly okay
oh my god no cube's not better it was
gonna roll but then
it isn't
[Applause]
oh i was wrong
that's something that's something
gymnastics just get in just get in
please help me
wait you stopped him from getting in
yeah i ran out of strokes i could do
nothing
that was legit god
that was legitness what okay i'm curving
it i'm curving it here we go that was
too much curve my duck my duck's getting
[ __ ] god damn it
oh that's too far little boy
a little little cone
i hate you oh i have a big [ __ ] idea
it didn't burn it didn't work
everything's [ __ ] everything's gone
had some benefits and that it stopped on
inclines i gotta say that helped out a
lot
okay
[Music]
always try to take advantage of others
around you
all right what it doesn't do yeah oh how
the cone has fallen so you could have
done that the whole time yeah yeah but i
was saved myself a stroke if i did oh
bob oh no who's coming out of last place
baby
yeah yeah yeah we'll see about that
we'll see about that uh the angle is
correct right now
oh this is wrong
oh my god
yes
i'm
gone
hey wait what what the hell
oh
[ __ ] oh god oh my god
oh holy get out of here
oh i found these myself
you beat yourself it's okay man it's
okay man
i thought i had to jump to get out of
the honey it's fine it's okay man
what's going on back here what's going
on back here
oh no the big cube isn't true
look at you
is is everybody else in oh yeah
everyone's
you got it are you [ __ ] kidding me no
that was a stroke
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right i'm not tied for last night
i was about to come
[Laughter]
you know what it is
you already know what it is
you all know what it is
here he comes big tunic you know what it
is oh god oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
it my goodness what's inside of you egg
stuff
you guys just get like 19 strokes for
the next three holes yeah i might we
pick
uh
i'm a man
joke's on you we're not golf balls but
we're playing golf
right
oh wait oh that was oh this is so much
worse where are we supposed to go okay
you pick the right one dummy
wait so which one is the right one the
right one
oh [ __ ] that's not where i'm headed
no no no no you might
oh no oh my god whoever just did that
saved my ass
god [ __ ] your
oh i see ah
interesting
ah
interesting
i got in one is that good
oh my god i'm oh oh truly
truly there is a god i did a horrible
experience which is the good one
i don't even remember i think it's the
middle one i got in one accidentally i
don't remember i'm not gonna make it do
it do it
i got in the middle one and it took me
back you have to get to the second level
and then get to the middle one
yeah dummy got there dummy
19 strokes without even getting to the
second part no you're you're in the hole
or something like that
please oh no
oh you're fine
you're an earthy cylinder oh no no no no
no
why am i a cylinder
is that helping
teed up this is the one hoof wait wait
wait look to your right look to the
right you see the statues
what does them mean it means that it
probably changes the correct one and now
the t is correct oh geez
are you kidding me that's why it felt
random
like yeah okay
i ran out of time
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
why would it be over
oh there's nothing
oh yeah oh yeah give it to daddy oh my
god i just dropped the whole thing do
not give it to daddy
did you honey my hole yeah i hunted your
hole honey where am i going oh my god oh
holy [ __ ] oh
[Music]
all right you want some of this there's
no no why why why simple geometry
you're fine just calculated
angles come on
barely i'm curving
oh come on
[Laughter]
whoa why
why do i have just let me go straight oh
my god what
what we take those here we take those
here sean i'm in a lot less trouble than
i used to be what oh
wow
yeah i think uh this feels like a last
place guys
a buggy
i mean
wait
sean how did you how did you not make it
it kind of just pushed me all the way
i'm an acorn like 95 of the time oh i
see i see i see i see
oh god you are right you
all the way
you know what it's about you know you
know what it is you know what it is
there you go
oh choice
mark said if i win the first one we're
never playing again
yeah he was real dictator about that yes
so all of you people watching this that
don't want to see more too bad i say no
[Music]
oh